this videos gonna be an interesting
experiment to see if we can put out and
quickly basically if we mess up one of
these shots tomorrow
the video is brilliant before you watch
this video make sure that you've gone to
the coridor channel and checked out the
world bouncy is - pogo stick this whole
video that you're about to watch on this
channel is spoilers for that video so I
recommend that you watch it first the
links right below me in the description
it's the second link check it out and
then click back and watch this video
because it's gonna make a whole heck of
a lot more sense if you do so Sam and I
have been thinking of this corridor
video idea it's kind of a continuation
of the world's blankety-blank series the
whole concept started as a joke between
the two of us a pogo stick just got us
laughing ren builds the world's bouncies
pogo stick shows it off to his friends
boy do is all the way up into that miss
fear and disappears when the camera pans
down we're in the same spot but it's a
hundred years later Ren's bones ball and
smash unceremoniously on the ground I
was there when the joke was originally
murmured I have a couple concerns if
it's not done correctly very quickly
become one of those things that's funny
to us and us only I mean so the question
becomes can they make an inside joke an
outside joke the main thing is we know
we need two shots he goes up and he
comes down we get a shot of Ren
explaining is a pogo stick and bouncing
away into the sky that's where we start
defying expectations we hold on the sky
he disappears and as we slowly start
panning back down a title comes up that
says 100 years later we show a spaceship
then we pan down further and we see a
cityscape and a future bag man your bag
men like you would be the scavenger so
final thing that happens right there the
sixth thing that happens is the bones
and the pogo stick come back down out of
outer space and that's already a lot it
doesn't need any more than that so
simple focused yet detailed execution
there's always this temptation
especially on the creative side to want
to add things because you want to show
off how much you are capable of to the
audience but I think the key
is really just boiling it down to what's
necessary if that doesn't happen this
this video is gonna fall completely
apart now we're shooting tomorrow and we
only have a couple hours today to prep
it I've been kind of slaving away over
this shot list here actually show you
I think it's complete in the second shot
of this video and there's like in this
trash hobo
he's like a scrounger we gotta find a
costume that suits that we got a lot to
work with here
I want this trash hobo to have that
guttural flair I think the layers will
be crucial here like layering different
things on top of it I love this these
are these rusty knee plates these are
great sewn leather what type of skin is
that hobos game I think we're kind of
assuming that they use pants in the
future
I need another layer the Shrek pocalypse
and yeah I get the accessories that
change it yeah that's better
[Music]
also I don't know what you wrap your so
now that Sam's approved this costume we
can make the pogo stick prop and then I
think we're good I need some cool future
lighting in here yeah of course you pick
Shrek green of course you know look so
here's our pogo stick you can actually
focus
nor screwing around no more goofs yeah
we're making a pogo stick what I'm doing
this is keep matching it with random
stuff that we have to make it look like
it's a technological achievement so this
is gonna be the solar panel front half
is silver in the back half because this
is for the moon light moon lunar panels
there's a button you just connects to
the capacitor upward thrust you're up
there I'm not making this up is like oh
we planned it this is the new and
improved world's most bounciest hooker
stick do don't God your whole life has
been a stretch thing you just didn't
know it distractions layers in honor of
today's sponsor crunchyroll I'm gonna be
commuting home on my new pogo stick
that's right you guys don't know
crunchyroll is the best place to catch
anime outside of japan they've got all
the new shows from all the new citizens
that are coming out over there and the
best part is it's made and created by
people who actually love anime for
people who love anime it's not just some
janky streaming service like this pogo
stick is where it's created by some
corporation to try to just make money on
some content that they don't know what
it's for it's actually got all your
favorite jokes by hero academia attack
on Titan ah Dragon Ball super and the
best part is a lot of the shows come out
only an hour after they air in Japan
another cool thing if you guys are
already members and you already know
about crunchyroll just know that's some
of the money you pay for your membership
goes to anime artists in Japan so they
really actually support the community
there which is another awesome thing
that I wanted you guys know that now
please if you guys already know Brock
our hero and you already watched shows
I'd leave a comment below about some of
the shows that you watch because people
who aren't into anime we want to know
could definitely benefit but I check it
out the show [ __ ] so anyway if you're
interested
go to crunchyroll.com slash corridor
crew and you'll get 14-day free trial
just by signing up what could it be
have you imagined actually just holding
its skeleton like this fine we mess up
one of these shots tomorrow and half the
video is not complete do you like those
steak students and we mess up one shot
the video is ruined bread since you died
in this video also I technically died
the end of the slingshot video too I go
to heaven
it's Brenda Kenny of Court oh yes oh my
god we're gonna sneak into the LA River
looks like there's a whole village that
sprung up around it so we might have to
like drive the city elder you know so
like what's this great it's like friend
comes in with the announcement guys I
built the world's bounciest attraction
well guys check it out I've turned it
this time stand back I don't wanna be
the shocked way it's gonna be
oh my god everything's called the ball
busters disappeared our baby boy when it
falls could either go like this and flip
around and the skeleton will just kind
of smack in or if it hits point first it
could bounce potentially and like we
don't know where it's going to go bones
- it's like mafia [ __ ] there we go you
know here's the pile this is my fault
alright the hit right there
I'm standing where it hit it's really
close
son that's
whatever oh no no no I'm doing it if it
hits the camera so be it because like
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing every single time we think
something's gonna hit the lens I hit the
camera most of the time it doesn't we'll
get a new lens if we really have to it
will suck obviously it'll be expensive
but the shots we get by being risky are
always worth it alright you guys ready
[Music]
thank you oh well too eager there buddy
pretty much landed exactly how I thought
it was gonna land just off to the side
but what I didn't anticipate was the
skeletons it completely like dismembered
itself on impact it's like squash that's
a wrap
goodbye pogo stick so we have two shots
and we have to merge them and make them
one shot with a hidden transition on top
of that we need to make an explosive
pogo stick effect and then we also need
to make this lavish cityscape this is a
thick tutorial to it an iPhone shot
which is the first step in video and
that goes all the way up until Wren
explodes flies in outer space so I've
been here I haven't picked it out then
to just get our super cool giant
explosion I'm using a ton of action VFX
elements here I like these dust
explosions a lot because it's a lot of
power there's a lot junk debris and also
a Video Copilot lens flare to cover it
all up
so here's Ren's element here just by
itself don't disappears he's going to
the head so basically I take Ren's body
and I turn it into a 3d layer and I just
send that 3d layer up to the
but here's where the crucial part comes
in the transition and this is kind of
like the hardest part I create a middle
shot that matches with the iPhone in the
beginning it matches with the red at the
end and that way I don't need to get too
specific with how these shots line up
let me show you a little bit how I did
that I start by adding in a literal blue
sky element that tracks up and down here
so if it pans up it pans up to my own
sky this is Sam's the sky I basically
have a hand animated 3d camera that
generally matches the iPhone so that way
when I can up the sky and the clouds and
ran all generally line up and are at the
right speed so the 3d camera is
perfectly smooth but I'm using one of my
favorite favorite plugins it's the red
giant camera shape now this thing is a
2d plugin what this is doing is making
it so that it still feels like we're on
the iPhone so I can have the realistic
camera shake slow down and then
perfectly become silicon we pan down we
bring the camera shake down will bring
some noise called grading vignette up
and best of all we bring up the big shot
to make the big shot we have a pan down
plate here I did the actual pan right
there while we were filming I didn't
leave that for After Effects sometime
just wanted to do that in post it looks
kind of fake and I use the cinema 42 the
camera tracking tool and from there I
built out this cityscape using a lot of
the kibish 3d packs and they are awesome
they're highly detailed we rendered this
out with cinema 4d and octane render
Nick boom
spaceship boom city boom haze alright
now let's put back in some action VFX
elements let's start with dust at camera
eight dust front 10 I did Nima's ashes
sprinkling side 0:04 you need a little
bit of grandfather's ashes at cam though
yeah for you all these cool dust
elements are pretty sweet but I figured
hey you know what I want to get this
thing a little bit of extra spice I've
been inspired by
friend of ours he posts a lot of really
great stuff on his Instagram and YouTube
channel Ian Hubert is an awesome visual
effects artist he's got this thing
called lazy tutorials and one of them
you can see a similar tutorial to what
I'm about to show you when the spaceship
comes over I don't want just a bunch of
stock footage smoke and dust coming I
want to do something that is part of the
scene I made some rectangles put
newsprint textures on them those were
then run through a soft body simulation
a cloth simulation technically so they
are actually matching the scene they're
matching the lighting they're matching
the lens to show the scale of this
spaceship basically Ren's skeleton was
filmed as a second plate as well this is
all we're doing we're just adding this
element in and then I do a light mask on
it as it collapses down to the ground so
that is the shot it's a lot of stuff
going on this video honestly it was a
really really fun experiment to and
building on a 3d city it's used in a
background definitely something I want
to do a lot more of so that's what went
into making the world's bouncies pogo
stick if you enjoyed this type of video
you know kind of the behind the scenes
look at how we make productions here at
corridor then you might want to check
out the second playlist down in the
description
it's chocked full of BTS videos and
other educational filmmaking experiments
that we've done who knows it might just
learn something thanks for watching
[Music]
welcome to the pogo lady without moving
your head challenge
[Music]
well Jake this is yours now